ragazzi allora di base io parto con i
video dove ho già aperto il gioco e si
vede già però questa volta registro
prima ancora di far partire il gioco
perché una volta schiacciato il tasto
play quindi ancora senza ancora arrivare
al menù di gioco succede questo va beh
vi chiede semplicemente con quale sa in
quale lingua voglio giocare ovviamente
l'italia non sarei cacciato nessuno
facebook
buongiorno a sullo stesso per te
comunque già è stato arduo partire però
schifo non al bando il dow ok scappa da
una casa abbandonata fino a qua tutto è
già stato un calvario farlo partire
ok ragazzi proprio questo erano al
vecchio stampo e questo fa vj 2013
signori ma che o no ma è sopra
evidentemente comunque mi fa piacere il
fatto che nella ne lascia ci sia del
sangue e io lasciano la prende perché
sento dei passi mi risveglio in una casa
orribile giustamente non non prendiamo
lascia che si chiama che mi difendo la
smettiamo di chiudere stavo dicendo la
smettiamo di chiudere i barattoli
sembravamo il rumore lì invece hanno
chiuso la porta
oggi sono dei piedi buongiorno
c'è un morto e vabbè non ha proprio una
bellissima faccia non credo sia lui a
far casino perché lo vedo bello steso
quindi non penso
alito pesante non ho capito come si
aprono le porte la porta non si aprirà
la chiave di sul primo piano e lo star
way back stage
ok c'era un tizio dietro fa niente non
tanto mi scusi porca put a aspettavo mai
va bene già partiti perfetti
il mona la partenza era giusta mi
piacciono
mi scusi si è aperta questa porta la
vedo bene secondo me lei una doccia sarà
potrebbe anche fare un mostro e rio non
ho mai capito cosa voglia di un'arma
tenebrosa è caduto
sembra che sia meglio andar via prima
che si alzi lo lesse sicuramente prima
che si alzi io chiuderei anche l'aborto
prendere lascia che ci lascia lì ma fa
niente lasciamola produrre eri e si è
alzato non c'è più non c'è più e cioè la
la e non c'è più ma chi eccolo 20 top
level bellissimo bellissimo c'è un
mostro orribile non si apre perché non
esaminiamo i dintorni è certo perché
vorremmo proprio aprire la porta si vede
proprio qui infatti arrivata lì alinghi
cos'è che mi scusi quanta gente c'è sta
carica insieme scusami quanti
coinquilini ciò questa casa abbandonata
è stata contaminata con un virus
la casa verrà bombardata perché c'è
stato è stata infettata non virus verrà
bombardata normale che ho letto per una
volta mi scusi lo sa che la casa viene
bombardata deve darmi una mano se non
cantiamo tutti in aria aiutiamoci a
vicenda se non moriamo tutti perché la
chiave del primo piano dal passaggio per
il mio piano genere
serve ho capito non c'è noi che non
siamo la stampa orta qui non si apre è
stato qualcosa sempre testa porta tra
l'altro ma guarda che mi serve ok ma
niente mi servono una delle chiavi qui
mi sembra ci sta forzando per bombardare
testa di culo stanno per bombardare
quindi o ti svegli o saltinaria solo to
check point perfetto e non ho capito
niente però la casa allegra io mi sarei
lanciato di fascia dalla finestra po di
volte ma cos'è sto casino qui ogni volta
che faccio entro in una stanza qualcuno
cammina dall'altra parte nella st
colonna lara gut artita la sigla ltc 500
cioè non stare attaccato al culo cioè
come possiamo chi si avvicina più sento
musica la porta è chiusa però il
complesso coeli per le porte del tg che
è ancora stata dove si aperta questa
vade retro continuare continua a darle
news
mi ha colpito si vede perché sono i
bordini di sangue vabbè ma cosa devo
fare qui macché gioco è quel ma
scusatemi un insulto a tutto l'orrore
mondiale non me ne voglio leggere il
giornale ciò satana nel culo
c'e una chiave qua prendila l'ho presa
dai lontano bob l'aggiustatutto versione
horror no perché c'è uno di chiavi bilal
in causa una panciera ho trovato una
chiave ma siccome io non posso perché
nel gioco non si può correre no io posso
andare passiamo questa velocità e anche
lui non per persone lente c'è nel senso
giusto cammino
questa è la mia massima velocità vi
giuro non posso darvi un ace di musica
ma neanche lui e col faccio se andare
solo così bella musica e avanti ho
trovato una rana si sfalda vodafone
credo che io debba andare nella prima
stanza che c'è la roba elettronica credo
non so magari troviamo
una pistola gli sparo vado avanti su
questo credo che una cena elettronica
eccola qua storage for del secondo e chi
è il problema che arriva a giovanni ha
penato porca vacca sono le fa pomaio vi
sta colpendo come non mai citato un
giorno c'è veramente queste loro più
brutto che abbiamo solo quali abbiamo
mai messo mano è veramente un po meno
certo la faccia quelli sono i fagioli
della nonna lo sento che cascata la
colonna bravo
tutto ciò cosa devo fare io quale non ho
capito bene un altro il k virus è molto
infettato infetti giugno e vabbè che
sempre mi scusi perché basta tirare le
posate le stoviglie cenere manca la
corre la calla colonna caduta da sola
ovviamente devo qualcuno alla corrente
perché devo accendere il quadro di
dietro
mi scusi ecco no non basta
la sigla i superquattro questa abbiamo
di nuovo governo
non si muove
ecco chi è quel mora che sbatte la porta
e successo a c l'enpals devo e
giustamente guarda non finirlo il gioco
va bene va bene così
questo signore e signori era accidentale
e non fate domande perché non avrei le
risposte creatore del gioco sistemano
questo video metti la corsa cioè il
satana alle spalle sei un po più il coro
anche per prendere il pullman io quindi
volendo anche se ciò uno dietro si può
fare bravi gli sia piaciuto e questo era
accidentale
devo un gioco difficile da avviare ma
bello da scoprire
vj 2020 segnati al canale lasciate mi
piace
beh ragazzi
[Musica]